[Applause]
I'm Samantha I'm the CEO of Givi studios
we launched Givi studios two years ago
as a creative agency and production
studio to make original gift content for
brands celebrities TV networks film
companies and music labels and more I'm
not going to talk about giffy or tech
today I've spent some time in a few
startups but at my core I'm a producer
and that gave me the foundation to
really thrive in these startup
environments so everything I ever needed
to learn to survive in business I
learned at Saturday Night Live I spent
11 years in the ultimate boys club where
many of the rules were drink lots of
alcohol exist on very little sleep
showers are optional and most
importantly work your ass off don't take
no for an answer
push boundaries take risks and be
fearless so today I'm going to talk
about taking risks and being fearless
which is funny because I'm quite fearful
of public speaking so please bear with
me right now I have some clips notes
right here so I started at SNL at 21
years old as a production assistant I
was bright eyed and eager and kind of
jaded as I entered the holy grail of
comedy you see comedy really wasn't my
thing I just wanted to work at The Oprah
Winfrey Show so despite that I did
understand the brevity of where I was
and it was thrilling I would stand on
set and hear the stage manager countdown
and we're live in 3 2 1 and I would just
get like butterflies of excitement
throughout my body and I can't say I
didn't get starstruck of course I did I
got to meet everyone and party with them
I went from drinking wine at 5 in the
morning with Eddie Vedder
to ending up at after-hours at Tracy
Morgan's where strippers were waitresses
and it would be like how is this my life
right now but the first day that I went
started at SNL someone told me whatever
you do don't talk to celebrities and
don't look them in the eye I think they
were trying to help me but I just spent
the next year walking around like a
hummingbird on steroids being like can I
talk to that person did I look at that
person the wrong way I got stuck in the
elevator with Lauren Michaels like on my
third week and just stood there frozen
like what's the protocol here am I
allowed to look at him I just looked
down and it was the longest elevator
ride of my life so I jumped into this
super competitive environment and
high-stress environment with very little
skills other than an internship at the
h1 and some college classes I really
just had to say yes to everything and I
made it up as I went along
it was either like I go with it or I get
eaten alive so I took a lot of risks my
second year I was asked to produce an
animated segment with a million dollar
budget I said yes of course why not
despite the fact that I had no idea how
to do a budget math was my worst subject
I didn't know how to use Excel and I
certainly didn't know how to produce
animation but I mean I grew up watching
cartoons so I figured how hard could
this be
right wrong there were a lot of
variables and it was near impossible and
to make it even harder I was really
young and doing a really big job so a
lot of people didn't take me seriously I
had to work extra hard to gain trust and
respect and it was constantly like
pushing a boulder up a hill I wish that
I could say that SNL was the only place
that I experienced that but it's
probably been almost every job I've ever
had for the sheer fact that I have boobs
I mean am i right anyway let's see I
forgot what I was saying because I just
talked about boobs and now I'm gonna
move too right okay farts
my first day as a producer of TV
funhouse I walked into this recording
studio and I opened the door and I heard
a loud fart out loud fart and I thought
are they gonna think it's me I was
really embarrassed and I sat down and
then there was another fart and I was
like what the hell is going on here then
I realized that we were doing a cartoon
and I spent four hours choosing fart
sounds from a fart library for a cartoon
from that point I went from fart jokes
to penis jokes at my next recording
session where I went to the ambiguously
gay duo with Steve Carell and Stephen
Colbert if then became my job to discuss
how phallic the animation was allowed to
be on SNL so that's how I became friends
with the NBC standards department
otherwise known as the censors so not
only was i pushing taking risks doing
things that I didn't know what I was
doing but I we also were taking risks by
the content we were making we were being
provocative and we were pushing
boundaries and there was a whole
department there to make sure we didn't
go too far and this was the standards
department and TV funhouse had a lot of
risks so I was number one on their speed
dial and I would get messages that would
tell me the exact words that I was
allowed to use for private parts and the
exact words that I wasn't allowed to use
let's just say these conversations were
NSFW the standards Department and Robert
didn't really agree all the time on what
was allowed to air on SNL so they would
tell me we couldn't air things and we
would do it anyway the hope was that we
would air it at dress rehearsal see
there was two live audiences a live
dress rehearsal audience and a live
broadcast audience and the hope was that
if it was funny enough Lauren would
fight for it and it didn't matter that
it was controversial I was basically the
sacrificial lamb
so since it was my job to get these
scripts approved it
was also my job to tell Robert we
couldn't actually make these things and
we would run our cartoon at dress and I
would walk off the set feeling really
high from all these people laughing it
doing really well and I would hear
Samantha
where's Samantha bellowing down the
hallway
I had no choice but to run and hide
fortunately most of the jokes got pushed
through and I didn't get into too much
trouble there were a few times though
where our risks didn't go as planned we
had a couple of cartoons that did get
pushed through and aired and then got
pulled from broadcast because they were
so controversial we did get threatened
by a lawsuit from Disney I got sued by
Michael Jackson for slander my parents
were so proud that they framed it on the
wall in the living room yeah they
finally thought I had made it so I
really learned the most about taking
risks from Robert Smigel he was the
ultimate risk taker and he never took no
for an answer and by default either did
I but there was one time where risk
almost destroyed my career so we would
air our cartoons and dress rehearsal and
between dress and air we would often
edit based on if the jokes played well
or notes from Loren Michaels and we did
this about 10 blocks away and we usually
had about two and a half hours to edit
based on where TV funhouse was in the
rundown so one time Lauren decided that
we should take our cartoon and cut it up
and have part of it be the cold open of
the show so when you see that that
person that's saying live from New York
it's Saturday night he wanted our
cartoon to do that now we had often
spent these two hours editing things and
I would be really cutting it close
running in New York City in heels with
the tape barely able to breathe I had
asthma and would always forget my
inhaler showing up to NBC at the control
room usually with about 15 minutes to
there now in this case we only had an
hour to chop up a five minute cartoon do
a new voiceover try to get the lip-sync
correct and we were ten blocks away it
was really scary I was looking at the
clock every minute it was just counting
down
counting down counting down and it would
have been our fault for the first time
in history since 1975 for SNL to open
with dead air if we didn't get the tape
there on time dead air for those of you
who don't know what dead air is it's
when you turn the TV on and you see
those colored bars with a really
annoying high-pitched sound not a good
look I would have been fired immediately
so I was really panicked and at 11:08 we
just had to call it it was going to take
us at least fifteen minutes to get back
to 30 rock so we lay off the tape get in
the car running with the tape Robert
Sprint's down the hallway gets to the
control room loads it in its 1127 we
made it whew except there was a problem
there was no audio we were
it was really really bad
Robert thought on his feet and went and
got Darrell Hammond who basically can do
every impression Under the Sun and had
him do Pat Robertson that's who we were
opening the show with gave him a script
and there were those words again and
we're live in three two one
only this time there were no butterflies
of excitement I was shaking in fear and
Daryl started reading the script live
watching the cartoon looking at the
lip-sync making sure that his words
matched the lip flap perfectly and then
it got to live from New York it's
Saturday night and went to the music and
I collapsed in my chair I mean my heart
was in my throat
somehow we pulled it off yeah I've taken
a lot more risks since my time at SNL I
veered away from TV into the YouTube biz
when it was really really new and I took
a chance at a startup called maker
studios most of my TV friends and my
agent all thought I was crazy but it
ended up being a really good risk
because I entered the Wild West of
startup culture and digital media and
it's led me to where I am now on a
completely different path than wanting
to work at The Oprah Winfrey Show I find
it much easier to get tripped up now
that I have like tripped up with fear
now that I have more responsibility in
my 20s I had nothing to lose I had no
fear of repercussions or what people
thought of me or god forbid fear of
failure but now with a career and a
family the risk seems much greater and
the fall from failure seems much harder
so whenever I find myself struggling to
take a risk I step back and I ask what
would that badass from SNL do and I dive
right in with nothing to lose
thank you
[Applause]